[Música]
despertando el deseo estimulando la
curiosidad la moda no deja de reinventar
su propia historia para despertar nuevos
antojos las colecciones crucero en los
años 20 estaban destinadas a unos pocos
clientes adinerados que escapaban del
frío invernal para navegar en los
trópicos hoy en día muchas marcas
ofrecen estas prendas de mitad de
temporada diseñadas para saciar la sed
de novedades la colección crucero
channel 2022 diseñada por la estilista
virgin y viable tienen lugar en alepo de
boone's en el corazón de un entorno
natural de piedra caliza
estoy asombrada de estar en esas calles
de liniers llenas de fuerza e historia y
de ver el desfile aquí fue un escenario
perfecto la belleza de las mujeres
destacaba enormemente esos trajes
blancos y negros tan gráficos
esta es la inspiración de gabriel sanz
pero también está la inspiración
definitiva con todo el lado con acción y
muchos más detalles de hecho que
establecen paralelismos entre el mundo
de gabrielle chanel y el de contó que
eran muy buenos amigos en 1959 a la
sombra de estas canteras doctor rodó
algunas secuencias de su película el
testamento de orfeo el poeta y la
diseñadora compartían las mismas
pasiones era una relación diría yo sobre
todo afectiva me emocioné mucho cuando
leí las cartas de jean cocteau a
gabrielle chanel se puede sentir un
afecto incondicional y al mismo tiempo
deseo fascinación y admiración mutua
también hubo una colaboración artística
entre ellos ya que gabrielle chanel hizo
el vestuario de varias de sus obras y él
diseñó algunos de sus vestidos y
encuentro que esta complicidad entre
ellos tiene algo muy conmovedor y de
alguna manera mágico
y creo que también existe esa necesidad
que tiene virgen y hoy en día de estar
rodeada de otros artistas porque eso
también crea una vibración
es un verdadero honor trabajar con
viejos y
pone su corazón y su alma en todo lo que
hace comprobando cada detalle de cada
modelo tengo que decirle que mi conjunto
favorito es el segundo es un vestido
blanco largo realmente me hace sentir
como un ángel
de
crucero bajo el mando de maria grazia
chiuri se celebra en un lugar
emblemático el estadio panathinaikó de
atenas grecia en 1896 el lugar acogió
los primeros juegos olímpicos modernos
hoy se trata de modernizar el peplum una
antigua pieza de tela que se coloca
sobre los hombros y permite que el
cuerpo se mueva libremente
starting
el punto de partida es un diálogo entre
dior y peplum el peplum esto es lo
contrario del estilo de monsieur dior
porque es una horma se trata de un
vestido que se tiñe al cuerpo de forma
muy personal no hay talla
así que es súper moderno y al mismo
tiempo nuestra herencia es la chaqueta
bar es un punto de vista completamente
diferente
monsieur dior era arquitecto quería
construir cuerpos definir fuertes
intenté trasladar algunos de los
elementos que realmente me gustan en
este tipo de vestidos como el pp porque
es ligero fácil de llevar
como dior es tradicionalmente sinónimo
de chaquetas hemos hecho una chaqueta
bar que se da muy suave y confortable
como factor
- construcción para más libertad
y para enraizar aún más su colección en
la tradición ateniense maria grazia
chiuri recurrió al modisto y bordador
griego aris terno back is en particular
para el diseño de la mítica chaqueta bar
y
hacemos coincidir nuestro patrimonio con
el local así que creo que podemos hacer
en la chaqueta bar este tipo de bordado
en la parte superior de la chaqueta para
la conexión etiqueta bar es una línea y
así es como se subraya esta línea que es
realmente dios
la chaqueta bar fue diseñada por
christian dior en 1947
estos ojales se inspiran en los chalecos
de las islas griegas los bolsillos se
utilizan en las costaneras las faldas
que provienen de la grecia continental y
el bordado continental también se
utiliza en la manga creo que está bien
después del bordado el trenzado
interviene en la confección de gorras
marineras decoradas con laureles de
yakarta donde cada pieza tiene su
importancia
las trenzas son muy importantes se
quitan y se pueden poner alrededor del
cuello así cuando el viento sopla nunca
se pierde el sombrero y cuando volvían
del marwijk era una tradición las
esposas saltaban la trenza aquí y la
ponían en su gorra así que las gorras se
convirtieron en amuleto de buena suerte
para los marineros el símbolo del hogar
la esperanza la felicidad la familia
a finas family las colecciones de media
temporada también pueden llamarse resort
y pueden vestir tanto a mujeres como a
hombres para la chispeante marca
italiana moschino a la próxima primavera
será alegre colorida y bailaremos al
ritmo de la música de los 80 y 90 como
funky town de steven greenberg everybody
dance the name rogers esta película fue
dirigida por el estadounidense jeremy
scott el dinámico director de la marca
colecciones crucero o resort
invitaciones a viajar en el tiempo y en
el espacio costoso sin duda pero muy
excitantes para perder sus inhibiciones
desahogarse y divertirse